tonight I've been calling out Hollywood
ports lack of diversity you know what I
don't want to just complain I want to
help solve the problem that's going to
take a fresh perspective so I went far
away from Hollywood I went as far away
from Hollywood as I could I went to my
favorite movie theater in Compton let's
take a look I in your own words what is
the Oscar controversy about what am I
guess it's about giving blacks a chance
to win were you upset when you heard
there were no black nominees this year
um actually I mean I wasn't surprised
but yeah I mean kind of bothered me a
little bit it was terrible I mean like
real bit like smack a white man bad
almost you still go to jail in LA for
smacking away minute
oh yeah out of the plane you're three
years for hard look
did you think about riding in Luton no
we did that already and I didn't get
nothing the first time I said oh well
this was your time to get that TV I know
right so did you see any of the
oscar-nominated movies you see a
spotlight no what the hell is that no I
didn't see never spotlight nope no do
you feel that Trumbo should have been a
bigger hit play how about Brooklyn no I
haven't seen Brooklyn did you see the
big short I did not
how about the bridge of spies where you
get it neat the movie making us that we
menthol on me right no this a real movie
I watch movie then come to the movies
all the time this these are real movies
like in London
did you see bridge of spies no no I did
not I've never our children never heard
of that movie Tom Hanks Tom Hanks I've
heard of him in Steven Spielberg yeah
I've heard of him
did you see Straight Outta Compton
Straight Outta Compton I loved at first
oh yeah yes I did oh hell yeah
what's your favorite movie of all time
so for black soup
now what was your favorite white movie
it here oh man
by the scene with Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie Wow not even they would say that
here's a real Austin I'm gonna give you
this I don't want you to look at that
camera and give your speech I want you
to tell Hollywood how you feel right now
um first and foremost like thank god
this should be not just white it should
be Asian Hispanic there's so much talent
out there of all races I feel like most
y'all kind of oh so you're not really
hip
so Wes you know the younger people like
I'd like to thank the Academy for
nominating yet another white person this
year I would complain but it was me so
maybe I'll complain next year you get
black oxygens more award because they
deserve and they work hard for just like
anybody else
how about that America
you